This is Adrienne Felt.
Adrienne is a PhD student at Berkeley, and she's done a lot of interesting work
on computer security.
So what do our students need to understand about security?
One of the first projects I looked at, which I actually worked here with Dr. Evans,
was I use Facebook and I install and use Facebook applications.
Many of you may be familiar with the Washington Post Social Reader.
And at the time I was just curious.
What are these doing with my data? How are they getting my data?
How do these things work?
And so I decided to learn more about how they work,
and from there it led to basically what ended up becoming my thesis topic in a PhD program.
I'm still interested in how do applications get data and how do they use the data.
When developers are writing applications that access users' private information
or resources like their location or their camera,
they need to keep in mind that they need to a) respect users' privacy
and only use the resources that they need to use,
and b) they have to be careful to build their applications in such a way
that they don't accidentally leak this data to other applications.
So I primarily focus on Android development and security of Android applications.
One thing that's really important for an Android application developer to know
is about the privacy and security of their applications.
So when a user installs an application from the Android Market,
they're shown things called permissions, which are small warnings
that tell the user about all of the resources that the application gets access to on their phone.
For example, for this application I'm looking at,
the application can get access to location, the Internet, the list of contacts, camera, etc.
So the user is warned before the application installation is completed
that the application can do all of these things.
So as a developer, it's important to only ask for access
to resources that your application really needs.
Otherwise you might unnecessarily scare off users
who might otherwise want to install your application.
So one of the projects we built was a static analysis tool
that analyzes the permission usage of Android applications
so that it can warn developers if developers are requesting more permissions
than they actually need for their applications to work.